you didn't want to be that george carlin
anymore he wanted to be a different
george carl what i really was was a
rebel
can't educate our young people can't get
health care to our old people but we can
bomb the out of your country all
right new hbo documentary called george
carlin's american dream about the life
of the groundbreaking stand-up star the
two-part biography shines a spotlight on
his multi-decade career and his life
offstage as well jamie wax has the story
jamie good morning good morning dana
yeah i mean come on this could have been
done yesterday this material the film is
co-directed by michael bonfiglio and
judd apatow who started out in stand up
himself before becoming one of the
industry's most influential creators of
comedy movies and television
judd apatow is best known for writing
directing and producing
blockbuster comedies like the 40 year
old virgin this is not a good look for
me i'm pregnant and knocked up with
emotion
but in recent years he's also made
detailed and thoughtful documentaries
about personal heroes like gary
shandling you know for 25 years he was
the most important mentor that i had but
in a lot of ways he was a mystery to me
and with co-director michael bonfiglio
the avett brothers there ain't no man
can't save me you thought the world was
gonna either come to us
or not i'm actually really happy with
the group that we got the two have
teamed up again for a two-part hbo
documentary that explores the life of
one of the most influential comedians of
all time would you all meet george
carter hey baby
what's wrong what's the problem what's
wrong with having a prison in your
neighborhood it seemed to me like it
would make it a pretty crime-free area
don't you think
for him 11 years old he's in fifth grade
it's what do you want to do with your
life and he writes down dj comedian
actor big deal he achieved all those
things really in his life right oh
absolutely he grew up at the time of
danny k and comedy was much different it
was probably bob hope and milton berle
people like that and that was his dream
to be
danny k
and became a dj while in the air force
and that led to like live appearances
surviving an alcoholic father and a
controlling mother meeting fellow dj
jack burns gave carlin a new outlet
creating the first of his onstage
personas as part of a comedy duo i think
jack was the person that was into
politics and was progressive
and george at the time i think was
from a conservative family and he
started you know rethinking a lot of his
ideas about things
carlin eventually set out on his own and
though his early approach was more
traditional below the surface there were
hints of what was to come i think the
conventional wisdom is that he was just
this straight-laced
suit-and-tie guy but he was actually
experimenting with a lot of more
subversive things sometimes sneaking
them on the air like with uh the hippy
dippy weatherman al sleet was clearly a
character that was stoned
this is a canadian low which is not to
be confused with a mexican high
prior to that he was doing things
talking about you know nepotism in the
kennedy administration and all kinds of
other
you know
subversive ideas
and sometimes it wasn't working for him
and he was trying to find his way
searching for his true voice carlin took
his material too far for his audience at
the time and lost a profitable contract
do you think this was like the first
huge hurdle for him
there was a series of things but that
was a huge one when he lost a very
lucrative contract at the frontier hotel
in las vegas and he realized that he
couldn't he was being held in by these
boundaries of the industry my work man
both my life and my work are going in a
direction of just being more natural you
know his work was then becoming more
authentic as voiced by many in the
documentary who he influenced it's like
he detransformed into who he actually
was
and that's that great moment that every
comedian wants to get to you know took
me a long time to get to it where the
person that you are off stage is who you
are on stage it really was about having
these really light
pieces just take a simple thing like the
word alter alter and change are supposed
to mean the same thing you can alter
your plans you can change your plans and
you've done the same thing
but if you alter your pants and you
change your pants
and then
switching at some point to these really
intense political pieces they arrested
me for profanity the supreme court
restricts the broadcast of dirty work so
he tried to give you a bit of everything
but it was all a setup to get to the one
thing he really cared the most about
life is sacred who said so god hey if
you read history you realize that god is
one of the leading causes of death
finding himself led to decades as a
hilarious truth-teller with routines
that sound as fresh and relevant now as
they did when they were first performed
pro-life conservatives are obsessed with
the fetus from conception to nine months
after that they don't want to know about
you they don't want to hear from you no
nothing no neonatal care no daycare no
head start no school lunch no food
stamps no welfare no nothing if you're
pre-born you're fine if you're
pre-school you're
the impact of that material has changed
comedy forever he personified that thing
that you see when you're young and you
go that that's it that's the thing
that's the thing to be
and i want it to be just
like him
getting every word in the right spot the
documentary also delves into george
carlin's complicated relationship with
drugs and with family life one of its
strongest voices coming from carlin's
daughter kelly
my mother was his biggest champion she
just had a way of lifting people up and
believing in them they were comrades in
arms but then what happened was
superstardom
she wrote a book about her relationship
and i think she has taken everything
that happened to her as a way to educate
herself and and to heal the core of the
story really is this relationship
between kelly and her her family hi
honey just got your letter the photo is
funny kelly's doing everything you
mentioned plus sticking out her tongue
he loved deeply as seen in these love
letters to his first wife brenda written
while he was financially strapped and on
the road i hate to repeat myself but i
must tell you this again i intend to
spend the rest of my life making you as
happy as you can be thanks for being
here with me for a little while tonight
thank you and even with all the
brilliant comic material george carlin
left us apatow and bonfiglio say the
humanity of his personal struggles are
just as important to remember
you can always change you know that that
people can always
grow and and reflect and and and change
and try to do better i look at it like
there's a a human
arc and there's a creative arc but more
importantly i just think about it as a
story of a young kid from an abusive
family who found a way to survive and
had a lot of hard lessons to learn about
how he could be a good parent and a good
husband and spend his life
trying to be a better person and got
there
he did more than get there the hbo
documentary george carlin's american
dream
is streaming now on hbo max and it is
just so well worth it i'm third i'm 30
minutes and about i couldn't resist last
night when i saw it dropped at eight i
was like i gotta watch and i started
watching and i was tired but it's so
good and i love him he is
everything all of his comedy routines
that i've seen resonate in some way with
me i can't explain it
timeless
exactly oh yes exactly yeah i mean they
really are watch it today and he's just
as good and the fact that he changed and
then they talk about it yeah you can
always change and he did yeah he evolved
for sure as a person his routine's
everything else you're still not going
to do the seven awards you can't say on
tv you know i already committed them to
memory at 14 and i said that i corrected
someone in the control room has their
finger over the bleed button right now
we tried to do it
please thank you